okay I have AC pledge Donna called
Heather that I owe Heather with why and
recently I was invited to pitch at a
investors conference for the princely
sum of a $400 monthly subscription which
was a annual it was an annual
requirement and that was a discount from
being $600 okay so five thousand a year
or 7,200 year paid in advance
well it was it was a committee
commitment it's a commitment so you know
you just you just pay the four hundred
then when I went on their website it was
you know it was clearly said you know
that if you cancel your annual
commitment you're responsible for the oh
my full commitment okay what's your
question so that came through a rich for
my blood
and also it seemed like you know if it's
an investor's Club where do the
entertainment and it's like what's the
name of this what's the name of the scam
I mean I have the company yeah I don't
wanna yeah I'm sure you want to tell me
come on let's go you of course you're
gonna tell me tell me
all right just texted I need to know the
name of this thing we need to know what
this is yeah you guys we have to out
these people these people are criminals
we must stop them but that's what it
seemed like to me you know I might my
backup in the film and reality the
industry and you know they're all these
kind of like predatory festival yes like
that okay and I'll explain this all to
you if you are an angel investor or
venture capitalist or seed fund or
accelerator in the world you are
searching for great entrepreneurs and
you're giving the money to get equity to
get on their cap table because that's
where the magic happens baller people do
not need $500
or $5,000 right now they need 5,000
shares for a penny each that become
worth $5,000 each and then you have a 10
to 1 stock split and then another 10 to
1 stock split and all of a sudden
they're sitting on millions of dollars
after they gave you 50,000
that's what baller angels are doing
that's what everybody in Silicon Valley
is doing anybody who is charging a
founder is a loser piece of garbage a
loser and a piece of garbage because
everybody knows that every penny a
founder has should go into product not
into paying off a bunch of [ __ ]
leeches who are pretending to be angels
and all you need to do is say oh that's
great I'm really interested I'll do the
I'll do the pitch for free if I get
value from it then I'll pay you and
they'll say no and then here's your next
teller this is a giant exactly I did and
that and do you know what they said oh
we don't do that we need you to come in
they said well there's a dinner and an
open bar I'm sorry are we here to get
free food
I'm here to build unicorns and
billion-dollar companies does anybody
need hors d'oeuvres literally yes these
guys fm
yeah and out dog and let's put some
light on just how horrific Li small
these people are this is a giant scam
Koretz ooh forum was charging people
$5,000 out here to present I knew people
who did it because founders are
ambitious and sometimes gullible and
sometimes desperate and they need money
and they're like well I get 5,000 I'll
get 500,000 back you know it's worth the
risk
yeah they would go everybody would come
after they pitched a curette so for him
and they would you know after they
presented they'd have like a little
networking they said everybody who came
up to them this is 10 years ago oh yeah
I'm an angel investor and I run a search
company so if you need any Talent oh
yeah no I run a consulting we do PR oh
yeah no I'm a marketing and you know I'm
a lawyer it was all service people and
he asked and what have you invested in
and they're like I invested in this
company back in the 90s or in this
company in 2005 it's like oh how much
should you invest like why I gave them
free
three months of PR they gave me 25,000
shares these people are garbage young
startups was doing this some company
young startups karatsu forum I have
destroyed these people I did it 10 years
ago on the podcast we can cut to me
acting like a maniac on the show with an
ak-47 in the first or second year
message to Mike scam Seagal
I am coming for you you will drop your
fees you will stop with the nonsense or
I will put you out of business and then
I want everybody in the nation to link
to it so when anybody types Mike Seagal
into Google this is the number one thing
that comes up you do not charge startups
thousands of dollars in percentage
points in their companies just to pitch
to angels it's insane it's insane Gary
Vee says it's insane we are coming for
you unless you do what Koretz informed
in why do we lay down like the dog you
are Mike Sugano what I am coming for you
I'm not educated enough why are they
able to justify that because desperate
entrepreneurs are first-timers like you
people calling it to the program they
don't know any better in some cases or
they're desperate and what these guys
have enough brand equity they made one
win or two wins or no whether you need
to have a debit cheesy-looking website
they pretend they have all these angel
investors coming they wear a suit
whatever and they don't know any better
end of the message these people get me
crazy and you know what Web Summit is
one of these people as well Web Summit
these scumbags were charging people they
were like they were going to my startups
my investments and saying it's normally
twelve thousand for us to give you one
day in the demo pit which they stole
from me and we're gonna give you you
know whatever these kind of meetings but
you know we talked to the team and
you're so great we're not gonna charge
you twelve we're gonna charge it just
four and you need to bring four team
members and I just don't tell anybody
and it's like I told my founders are you
dumb you're gonna be $4,000 for
something that you don't need to do and
there's no investors there and it's 99%
you know founders looking for money you
put yourself into a cattle call and you
paid to do it it's so dumb
that's why we give a look at look at
what we do we give away free tickets to
the events we give away free demo pits
we have found University it's free why
because we're playing the long game
we make more money on a unicorn than we
could one unicorn investment is going to
make us Millions tens of millions
perhaps even over a hundred million
dollars from one unicorn investment
that's what you get if you're an early
seed stage company why on earth would
you be playing the game for $500 a month
from a two-person startup for the love
of God these people are garbage
it's fury ating well that's give me the
name come on Nick you want to give me
the name let's take these guys right now
let me do it let's take him out let me
tend to Seattle but they did you today a
like a like a like a gold sock on their
on their website it was like really it
was like so close to that that's higher
festival that like club that he had
before it was like exactly like it gives
you a watch like if you join you know
such garbage
yeah pretty wild all right listen what's
going on with your startup tether I know
you love the show thank you for calling
I appreciate that well what's this Tyler
tell me about your startup what do you
do it's it's a it's faster streaming
video it's a little baby unicorn yes yes
for streaming video so instead of using
YouTube for streaming you're like Wistia
you are like white label private for bit
it takes everything takes everything
it's a multiplier it's not a disrupter
everything goes in and increases
engagement and it works as a work
product anything it's like going from a
manual transmission to an automatic
transmission so the user experience on
video it's awesome awesome and are you
charging for it yet or you're just an
alpha right now right you're trying to
figure out product yeah I'm going to
show your media team if Brent and they
if they school they'll show it to you
next week
fantastic here's what I suggest when you
do in the alpha testing and everything
charge people yeah charge people make it
real
see if the product is good enough that
people will pay a lot of times people do
this Alfa's and i do these betas they no
charge and then they get disconnected
from that feedback loop ask people to
give you their credit card charge them a
hundred bucks you can under charge them
that's fine but charge them nonetheless
I take it seriously in their respect
that's my one piece of advice legitimate
aspirin
that's really interesting I appreciate
that I thought also that that the
engagement would go up and people would
spend more time interacting with video
you know video is getting huge obviously
and you know any tools you can make
around it are a nice business if you can
build a SAS product that's a monthly
product that is a little more robust
into some full-stack version of stuff
then it gets more interesting and then
if it becomes a platform or a
marketplace then it becomes super
interesting so a lot of times people
start with a tool then they build a
product then they build a solution and
then they build a platform or
marketplace right and every time you
make that yeah but every time you make
that jump you can add a zero to the
valuation or total addressable market so
I encourage you to start with a tool
that's fine tinker around solve a
problem with the tool but then try to
build the full stack solution so if you
want to do Silicon Valley style empire
building send me the name of those
scumbags so I can go after them I will
destroy them on social media I will make
them rue the day they ever tried to take
advantage of one of my listeners I will
destroy them get me that name Jackie
alright thanks for calling in appreciate
you and appreciate you